smile no Richard McCaig spent the last
month of his life volunteering as a
carer in his community until the
symptoms started he said he wasn't
feeling well he started with a bit of a
dry cough I was a but we was
joking about it are you gonna get ill
and he just deteriorated really really
rapidly so he couldn't eat couldn't
sleep he couldn't walk he couldn't
breathe that called one-one-one for a
bit of advice and they sent out the
paramedics
Richard was taken to hospital but his
condition worsened the nurse the sister
called me and she explained that um his
body was tired he was exhausted he
couldn't take in the oxygen that he
needed so they've made the decision to
put him on a ventilator so he did
message me and he said you know babes
were gonna put me on a ventilator and
he's like Olivia I love my grand please
I'm a grand that I love her and then he
said thank you for the best life Ricky
wrote it's a 50/50 chance
those aren't great odds signing off once
I'm asleep it's in God's hands a nurse
then held up a phone so that Ricky could
video call Katy it was the last time she
saw him alive
the next day while driving she received
a call from the consultant at the
hospital he's hard the call was less
than two minutes long you know it was a
matter of I'm really sorry - ring yeah
as we were turning Richard back onto his
stomach he suffered a cardiac arrest and
we wasn't able to resuscitate him so I'm
sorry but he's passed away and I'm
driving I'm on my own
and what's hair and I would just kind of
like oh oh okay thanks ringing because I
just I didn't I didn't know how to react
I think I'm still waiting for him to
come home at 29 Ricky is one of the
youngest victims of this crisis his
family say that it is too early and too
risky to begin to think about lifting
the lockdown all me and his family want
to do is stress the people stay home you
know Baris has been telling you on TV
for weeks
celebrities are telling you the news are
telling you it's everywhere but people
are getting complacent now because it's
been so long you know I'm a senior
reports all we want to loosen the
lockdown and viruses say no it's not a
good idea and I agree with him if they
just follow and what they're asking them
to do I don't think we'd be in this
situation like so many others Richard
couldn't have his family beside him in
the end
a cruel hallmark of this disease Nick
Martin Sky News